[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we are here we are live as we are every
single weekday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific on YouTube Twitter and twitch
I don't know are you are you on the
tubes of you or are you on the Twitchy
machine are you on the books of face if
you're on on Facebook right now you know
we broadcast from my Facebook page and
the Midas touch Facebook page so don't
forget to follow both if you're on the
books of face if you're on the tubes of
you hit that subscribe button it's not
that difficult just click it and then
maybe the Bell notification you're not
going to want to miss a thing here on
the Tony Michaels podcast
we bring it to you real and raw every
single weekday
for two full hours two full hours
yesterday was a great show
we had Texas Paul on Gabe Sanchez I mean
you here's the thing with the Tuesday
Texas Paul the original idea was Paul
wanted to come on every week we had this
great idea hey come on every week he's
like yeah let's do it on Tuesday
because that day works for him and it's
Texas Paul Tuesday yeah right again it
goes right now
this Tuesday Texas Paul was traveling
he was traveling because he was
secretly having CIA meetings apparently
that's what the right wing thinks that
uh in Texas Paul is part of the CIA deep
State CIA so they thought he went to
Washington to have secret meetings
I guess I'm not really sure exactly what
the [ __ ] all that means I don't know I
ask that that right-wing Nut Job Allison
over on oan
uh he did a rebuttal video which we're
going to ask about him next week I I
know you want me to cover it today
because it has already happened but I'm
gonna cover the Texas Paul rebuttal
next week when he's here I want him to
to tell us more about it so go go check
out um his follow-up from being accused
or being um
doxed as um CIA secret CIA oh my God
he's
he's a Secret
Agent Man I don't know
I don't know what the [ __ ] these people
just they get all kinds of [ __ ]
deluded they get all kinds of crazy
ideas in their heads and they just run
with it
and a lot of times it's funny in
particular this time where they this
Allison right-wing crazy q and honor
oan host
and uh social media bigot she's a bigot
running around yelling screaming people
taking down LGBT Flags off their
buildings as if it's her [ __ ]
business what flag they fly outside
their building I thought these people
were for freedom of speech they're
really [ __ ] dumb
but
I mean what do you expect out of this
group of people man they're still
they're still supporting an orange
Mussolini Jesus
who was not having a easy time not just
in his own little world but his
candidates as well you notice that the
um
the title is Herschel Walker pays for
more abortions and I'll get to that
but I want to get back more to this CIA
stuff
um because Texas Paul joined us
yesterday because again Tuesday he was
doing Secret Agent CIA [ __ ] I know I
don't know uh what they claimed he was
doing
um he was like traveling because he went
to Washington
um to the White House because the White
House called him and when the White
House calls you you go no matter how
much it cost you you you go uh so
um but here's the thing
today I just want to let you know
because it has been it has been said
Gabe Sanchez told me this it has been
said that he's a Fed so today Gabe
Sanchez is not he's not on a film set
yet
that I know of
so he's not shooting deep State
propaganda videos
um to go to Washington to give to the
CIA I I would imagine for that rigged
algorithm that Allison claims that there
is
but it appears that he's doing Secret
Agent CIA stuff and I think Gabe Sanchez
might be listening out there
um as he's doing these covert left-wing
libtard CIA operations to rig the
algorithms
I don't know it could be a thing
I what do you think about this because I
I still don't believe that elon's gonna
own Twitter
um even sometime tomorrow they're saying
that he's gonna own it but I I actually
don't think he's going to come up with
the money unless the Saudis step in or
Putin well you think that maybe was his
meeting with Putin he's trying to no one
else will lend him the [ __ ] money so
he takes the road to Trump
he takes Trump's advice you know just go
go to your to your foreign your foreign
enemies your foreign adversaries and
just borrow the money there they'll give
you the money especially with Twitter I
mean really honestly Putin and the
Saudis would love would love for Elon to
own Twitter wouldn't they God damn the
Republicans would too I mean they love
them some Kanye they love them Elon and
they love Trump they tweeted the [ __ ]
Elon
Kanye Trump is what they tweeted they
love they love these [ __ ] boxes [ __ ]
love them well I mean it's not a
surprise they're back in Herschel Walker
aren't they
[Laughter]
oh man you just can't make this [ __ ] up
really honestly um we're less than two
weeks away from this election
um and more and more people are
spreading videos and pictures of how
they're getting out and boating early
getting their mail-in ballots I'm
talking to people canvassing uh folks I
am not a naysayer here I am not a
defeatist that is not what we're gonna
[ __ ] do here on the Tony Michaels
podcast you can guaran damn T that we
are going to fight fight fight all the
way till the end and even when the votes
are cast
and they're counted certified the
election's done
the the the Democrats who do lose
concede and the Republicans who do lose
spread lies
we will continue to fight we will not
stop
because this election that is about to
happen in less than two weeks is the
most important election of our
democracy's lifetime and maybe democracy
altogether
maybe democracy altogether
because if this one Falls these fascists
will believe that they can topple any
democracy around the world
if they toppled the American democracy
the beacon of democracy
the standard
of the West
now
I'm not a defeatist
I don't believe that Democrats don't
have a chance
because right now is your opportunity
that's the main thing that's why I'm so
confident that's why I that's why I'm so
optimistic because of you
holy [ __ ] we get we get hundreds
thousands of people who come here just
to this little tiny show every single
day
and they engage
and they're not they're not just
engaging
in the chat about what I'm saying
they're talking to each other they're
sending guidance to each other hell
they're even trying to help each other
with mental health
in the chat giving each other
encouragement
sending Sending message of empathy you
are the best audience in the world I
truly believe that and it is growing
because of that because of you
because you are so engaged
that's what gives me confidence that's
what gives me hope
that's what gives me optimism not
defeatism
because democracy is done by the people
and not not the few
the mini
and we are the many right here on the
Tony Michaels podcast you are the mini
and it's here's the thing it's not just
people in America I know I cover
American politics
and I cover the shittiest of the shitty
of the American politics here on the
Tony Michaels podcast
sometimes it's almost laughable what
these pieces of [ __ ] are doing insane
but we have to listen we have to know
but you are engaged not just here in
this country but all around the world
and that gives me even more confidence
that the world wants democracy the world
is willing to come to this small show
yes it is small but we are growing baby
oh we're growing and we're going to take
them by surprise we're gonna take them
by surprise
because I know you're not gonna quit so
I'm not gonna quit we're gonna keep
going
and that's what they're scared of
that's why they're they're scared
and it's not just the Republicans and
the fascists
it's also the establishment and power
that are terrified
of a movement like this
now I see you as the best audience in
the world because you want democracy
and it's not just here in this country
it's all around the world we have
viewers all around the world that come
here every day
to hear the cathartic Outburst the
yelling and screaming into the
microphone
to show you what optimism can be like
that it's just not quiet dumb repeating
of statistics
which left Wingers always do they don't
they want to be nice they're tolerant
well we here at the Tony Michaels
podcast are intolerant of intolerance we
will not [ __ ] put up with it won't
happen
not going to happen here
and I know that is why you come here
every single weekday
and I know that's why I am so optimistic
about our democracy not just here at
home in America in the U.S of a the
United States of America
but all around the world
folks
Liberty
is freedom like that's what it is that's
why it feels so good to have Liberty
and sometimes if you're not aware what
Liberty actually is because Liberty and
freedom is not going into the grocery
store and having 36 frozen pizzas to
choose from
that's not Liberty
that that's not freedom
the ability
to leave your home
even though you are
a certain type of person a certain color
of person people of color lgbtq
rather you're a certain religion
when you you are allowed you have the
Liberty to go out into the world and
they can't put a sign on the grocery
store where you're gonna go buy your
frozen pizza where you have 36 choices
they're all the same company by the way
that makes all those [ __ ] pizzas
yeah maybe two or three
listen
you have the Liberty to leave your house
and go into that store and buy
whatever Pizza that you want
that's the Liberty that's the freedom
to be able to go to be able to move to
be able to make those choices
rather it's Dr Oz at a fake grocery
store called Wagner's
is that what he called it I don't know I
I don't know the grocery stores in
Pennsylvania so I wouldn't claim to know
he does he claims to know
or if you choose to go across the street
to the competition
and buy from them that's your Liberty
but they can't put a sign out front
saying well
no transgender people that can come in
no people of color
no people of this religion
this sounds all familiar right
this is what fascism breeds this is
where it goes folks
this is the slow steps that they're
making they want to ostracize people
from society
hell they're writing history out of
books
and out of our schools that's why they
want to that's why they want to disband
the Department of Education because it
would actually educate people
and that they can't have that they can't
oh they can't have people learning the
truth
and that's why they're running scared
and that's why I'm optimistic I mean
hell they they hate that I sit here and
talk every day they're terrified that I
sit and talk every day they'll say stuff
like oh that guy doesn't know what he's
talking about or blah blah blah yeah but
here's the thing they're terrified of my
voice
and they're terrified of you hearing it
because they know that you'll you will
create action
it's you they're scared of
they don't want you to hear my voice
because you
will put it in action and that is
exactly what you need to do over the
next two weeks
you need to bring their worst fear to
fruition here
give them exactly what they what they
all deserve
which is a mountain of votes piled on
top of them
don't let these [ __ ] intimidate
you
don't let don't let these these weak
pieces of [ __ ] who are sitting with
their with their [ __ ] faces covered
who by the way are the same
[ __ ] that were bitching about
face master and coronavirus I'm sure but
now they got their faces covered when
they're trying to intimidate people at a
ballot drop box do not let them
intimidate you if you go to the Post
Office don't let them [ __ ] intimidate
you if you go to the polls
do not let them intimidate you check
your vote like Texas Paul was saying in
Texas and do not let them intimidate you
that you can you can make sure that your
ballot is cast the way you want
yesterday I had a friend
he moved out of state
he messaged me because he listens to the
show
he's probably listening right now
and he moved out of state recently so he
doesn't have a state ID in the state
that he moved to
and that state unfortunately has a
stupid ID law
well because he just moved there and
they just bought a house
they don't have a permanent address
because they don't live in that house
yet they live in a different house
with some family
while they're getting their
other house clothes so they can move
into it you know
just the transition thing but it's all
happening during this election and they
want to vote because they know how
important it is to vote
they know how I'm he's literally
crawling over hot coals here he moved
out out of state to a different state
with the state ID he's got the wrong
state ID
because he came from another state
right
now in that state the state law says
that he can use other forms of ID which
he had but when he went to the actual
poll he had his voter registration
because he did change that
but he's not able to get his ID yet with
his new address on it
so he goes to the poll and when he scans
his
voter registration ID you know the one
the county send you and most prob most
counties probably send these out you
know it's just a piece of paper
sometimes I think sometimes it's a note
card
it just depends
but it that is a voter ID it's not a
photo one
but it is issued by a County department
where are you registered to vote
it kind of tells you you know where the
hell you're supposed to vote a lot of
times like what what location
well he had because of all this address
change he had an absentee
excuse for this to go and vote
and when he went in
he didn't have the correct photo ideas
from a different state
and they told him nope you can't vote he
said oh no [ __ ] I can vote I read
the law I checked with the county I
checked with the election office
and they told me I just have to have a
this form of ID and I have it
and they him hauled and and told him no
a couple different times and he stood
fast he didn't leave he didn't back down
he didn't say oh well I tried nope he
stood right there and said nope I've
been told I can vote
and they finally they finally got it
together and realized that yes what he
was saying was true
and they had to let him vote so don't
don't back down
there's a video going around I guess and
maybe I'll play it uh our friend Walter
Masterson uh posted it earlier I haven't
watched it yet but I did see he posted
it of a woman who uh supposedly had her
ballot they didn't want to take it at
the post office
so we will um we'll watch that video
maybe but again it is so important that
not just you but encourage three people
and encourage them to stay fast don't
don't give up
if they give you pushback this is your
constitutional right and and by God if
you don't use it this time
you may not be able to use it again
if they have their way
they don't want your vote to count Jesus
Christ they got they got all kinds of
secretaries of state that that are Trump
humpers that are election deniers think
about this
Trump humping [ __ ] moglodytes
who are running for Secretary of State
in the Republican Party are election
deniers
in Most states the secretary of state is
the is is the head of Elections
they're the chief officer of Elections
and you want people who can't even
[ __ ] can't even pluck their head out
of their long their asses long enough to
figure out that the facts that are
beared before them
and the lies that no one's been able to
prove
just because they don't like the outcome
that's why
[ __ ] them who cares what the out who
cares whether they agree with the
outcome or not pile them under mountains
of [ __ ] votes
and that's the other thing that gives me
confidence
and I've said this before and I'll keep
saying it I'll repeat it over and over
and over again and I'll keep beating
this table
Joe Biden did not get 81 million votes
for him
a lot of those votes a lot of those 81
million votes were against Trump
and Trump's on the ballot he made sure
he's on the ballot
Herschel Walker Dr Oz JD Vance Kerry
Lake Blake Masters every single one of
these [ __ ] trees in the Secretary of
States that want to take away your vote
Brian Kemp Greg Abbott
Eric Schmidt in Missouri Ron Johnson
you name him
he's on the ballot
because they will bow down to him that's
what they want as authoritarianism
they have figured out that democracy
does not work for their ideas because
their ideas [ __ ] suck
and they know that we know that they
[ __ ] suck that's why they don't even
talk about their ideas anymore
they just try to scare people about oh
genitalia
CRT
what the border the Border
Fentanyl
scary words spooky language scary words
they don't have ideas because all their
ideas [ __ ] suck
they they [ __ ] suck what idea do they
have what what idea
so it's up to you it's up to you
to go to the ballot and to encourage
three people to go hell give them a ride
if you have to
and make sure those three people
encourage another three people
and I know that scene like oh come on
Tony that that seems cliche no it's not
I have three people three people myself
personally that I have encouraged to
vote
and I just told you a story of one of
them
and he made sure to crawl over hot coals
to vote he made sure that his wife and
and hopefully he'll make sure more of
his family members are friends go vote
however they vote I don't give a [ __ ]
how you vote I really don't care
actually honestly I want I wish everyone
that could and is eligible to vote in
this election would vote so we can
really [ __ ] see we can see how
unpopular this nonsense is because
that's really the fraud no one wants
this garbage telling us what the [ __ ] we
can do telling you what you can do with
your body telling you telling women what
[ __ ] medical decisions they can make
telling anybody if they can have
contraception telling people what
religion this country is or what [ __ ]
religion they have to be what you what
what [ __ ] delusional [ __ ] your
children need to [ __ ] be brainwashed
like Christopher Columbus is a founding
father
Johnny Appleseed and blah blah on and on
and on and [ __ ] on we talked about it
yesterday with language
with calling indigenous people other
[ __ ] that isn't true
that's what they that's what they want
and I don't believe the American people
want that nonsense it's just garbage
it's trash and and they're tired of it
they are the exhausted majority but
they're not going to sleep
they're not giving up
they're tired of your [ __ ] and they're
fighting back
because that's what we're going to do
here on this show every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter and
twitch and simulcasting from Facebook
the Midas touch Facebook page and our
Facebook page we're not going anywhere
folks you can also download every single
episode
on Apple Apple Spotify Google make sure
when you're there downloading that you
leave us a review there's going to be a
lot of trolls probably leaving reviews
so make sure you leave a review when you
subscribe to the show there and again if
you're on YouTube go ahead and hit that
subscribe button it's really easy it's
right down below just hit subscribe
I hate that YouTube calls it subscribe I
wish it was always follow because you
don't actually pay for this
it'll pay for this this is all free
that's right it's free I believe that
this two hours a day should be available
for everyone to hear and everyone to
share and it shouldn't cost you a thing
to do it that's why we broadcast on any
[ __ ] social media or any place that I
can
I don't gate the content here I don't
gate it I don't charge you I don't make
you pay something now if you want to we
run on your support this is how we do
this
you can and and you can give us monetary
support you can go to tonymichaels.live
and you can leave a one-time tip or you
can leave a monthly tip you can set it
up monthly so you don't forget it set it
and forget it as they say
the other way that you guys uh support
this show which is uh holy moly uh you
guys love this design the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not Liberty and damn it I didn't bring
my hood I got my hoodie downstairs this
thing is warmer than [ __ ] I I have to
actually unfortunately take it off you
know branding purposes I'd love to leave
it on but I have to take it off because
it's so damn warm
it's not cold enough yet and it's just
it's just a I bought the zip up one the
zip up Hoodie I'm not much of a pool
over hoodie I like the zip up hoodies
I'm glad someone suggested to put it in
the zip up and it's super popular our
most popular design on store dot need
Tony michaels.com that's
store.thedonymichaels.com
you can get the pullover or you can get
a sweater even or the zip up like I
bought they're super warmer you can get
a t-shirt but it's cold outside it's
getting cold
and as you're waiting in line to vote as
you're making sure that nothing's gonna
stop you from saving your democracy you
want to stay warm so go to store that
detoneymichaels.com that's door dot the
Tony michaels.com
for all your Liberty merch
I do have I do have oh someone someone
may have brought me
um my assistant
may have brought me my uh my my hoodie
here uh here here is the here's my
hoodie I got a black one the zip up one
there you can see you can see the hoodie
there I don't mess around I like
I like the design and it's warm it's
warmer and [ __ ] oh my God it's warm
Baby It's Cold Outside a lot of people
don't like that song but Baby It's Cold
Outside so go get you a liberty hoodie
that's stored in that beat Tony
michaels.com that's
store.thedonymichaels.com
I I want to tell you that um
I I know you're sad that Gabe Sanchez is
not going to be joining us today but
never fear never fear tomorrow's Friday
tomorrow is Friday and you know what
Friday is here at the Tony Michaels
podcast it's bone head of the week we
practice every single week voting every
[ __ ] week we practice it here at the
Tony Michaels podcast we vote for
bonehead of the week you vote you decide
who is the bonehead of the week and me
and my great co-host Gabe Sanchez rather
he's with the CIA or the feds I don't
know I don't know what's going on today
no really he's he's in the air he's on a
plane he's on a plane
but here's the thing
tomorrow
he will be broadcasting from an
undisclosed location we will be doing
bonehead of the week so make sure you
subscribe to the YouTube channel because
you can vote there or you can go over to
Twitter that's that's uh just as
important at Tony Michael's pod you can
vote at Tony Michaels pod on Twitter
bonehead of the week poll
we're gonna do some shitless Roundup
because yesterday we didn't get to do a
lot of it because Texas Paul stayed
around and we talked a lot about spam
and all kinds of [ __ ] so stick around
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after these messages
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the word that I'm struggling with I
chose babblemag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show thanks
for sticking around through the break
you guys love Gates and parody
commercials and funny as [ __ ] we have a
surprise coming for you in the next few
weeks those commercials are gonna get
serious no I mean they're gonna be funny
but they're seriously going to be
commercials that's literally that
they're going to be commercials we have
some sponsors coming some surprises I
think you guys are gonna like I think
you guys are gonna like the sponsors I
really do
um they're great they're a great group
of guys they they uh they do great work
for our democracy and they're not scared
to beat pro-democracy even though they
are a company they do not give a [ __ ]
they do not like Maga they do not like
them in a house
with a mouse
in a tree just let them be they do not
like manga at all
um so I think you're really gonna like
this company
um and um we'll be making announcements
over the next few weeks and I I tell you
what what will happen is we're still
gonna air that your favorite commercials
maybe we'll make some new fake ones but
there's gonna be some funny real ones
some funny real ones so we're working on
those right now
um and I hope over the next month or two
we can really grow these sponsors
because they're again they're a great
company a great group of people and and
really honestly the reason why we want
to have them here is because I know you
will want to support them
because they are anti-fascist they do
not like this trumpism [ __ ] they do not
like this garbage and they are not
scared to say it even though they're
corporate even though they're a company
they are not scared to say it so I I
hope you I hope you stay tuned to some
of those announcements that would be
making very soon we're very excited
about it we're very excited about it I
want to tell you about a couple other
things before we get to the shitless
Roundup too I've mentioned this movie
um and I I Melissa Joe is is a friend of
mine she's the director of this film
and she's a she's a friend of mine and
um so I I'm not this is not a
sponsorship but but I definitely want to
tell you go watch this movie
go watch this movie this is this is
super important and if you go watch it
on Amazon make sure to leave them a
review
um a lot of people have been watching on
2B as well I think it's spelled t-u-b-i
now some people have been um sending me
some tweets and some DMS saying hey this
was a great movie they watched it
because I said it here on the Tony
Michaels podcast and and they they went
and watched it on Amazon or 2B and you
can find it there but you can go to uh
let's see the website I don't want to
mess it up
let me make sure I get the website right
I know the uh moderators because we have
the greatest moderators in the world
probably have the website handy but it's
I think I believe it's the game is up
movie yes it is the game is up movie.com
here I'll put it in the chat so you guys
can um you guys can go check that out
here here we go
yeah look I'm I'm by myself today you
know
this is how so you gotta run the show
and be the host and talk so there you go
there you go there is the the movie the
game is up
Melissa Joe my my friend is the director
of the movie it is a great movie now
uh let's play the trailer and then I
want to talk about the movie and I want
to talk about another movie that
everyone in the comments because I
brought this up and I've had a few DMS
about this other movie so let's play the
game is up trailer right now when you're
in the conservative media world like I
was in you are told to say every day
that Donald Trump walks on water
I was told by my bosses to only say good
things about Donald Trump I told them to
go
most of our opinions about Donald Trump
do not come from CNN or from MSNBC
orphan Fox most of our opinions about
Donald Trump come from Donald Trump
himself I'll actually get over and I
should move on how can you I mean they
lied about liberals lied about Democrats
line about Trump it's kind of hard to
invest in wine
I know quite a few uh people my age who
are in the Republican Party who they're
thinking about leaving the Republican
Party they're thinking about leaving
this trumpism this phenomenon I threw up
the red flag I threw up the White Flag
as a warning that this was bad
agricultural policy and it was going to
hurt us for a long time
foreign
so there you have the game is up so go
to the game is upmovie.com the game is
that movie.com it's a great movie it it
it breaks down different people from
different walks of life who are Trump
supporters who became disillusioned very
quickly now a lot of this movie was shot
during the pandemic right
um but it's a great movie and really
honestly I believe I've watched it but I
believe I I've watched several parts of
it and then I watched the whole thing
but I'll tell you that I believe it's a
great movie to share uh not just with
your relatives who agree with you but
your relatives who don't agree with you
super important very very very important
to share it listen that's what you have
to do to engage you have to lean into it
you have to lean into democracy
sometimes you just gotta deliver the
truth to people and and honestly hear
in this movie The Truth is bared from
Trump's former Trump supporters who
supported him who voted for him who
campaigned for him even
were on the campaign for him
so go to the game is upmovie.com again
you can watch it on Amazon and a lot of
people have been saying they watch it on
Tubi and I believe it's spelled two
t-u-b-i I believe that's the app or or
the I think it's a service that you
that you pay for Content or something
and it's on there you can go you go find
it on 2B are you mind it on Amazon or
you just just go to the game is
upmovie.com and you'll find your Links
at the website and again if you can
leave them a review that would be great
that would help my friend Melissa Joe
out she's the director and I'm go you
can even go follow her on Twitter
um at Melissa jpoptier but Melissa Jo
again we appreciate your hard work on
this film I really enjoyed it and I
think it's a great piece of content it's
very important another movie though that
everyone's been pointing out and again I
I this isn't a sponsor thing it's just
um the um everyone's been saying and the
mods have pointed out to me I believe
too that hey there's this other movie
that
um
that it is kind of the same thing but
it's an older movie and I believe if I'm
not mistaken let's see if I can do see
if I can find the
hmm
let's see it is called
um the brainwashing of my dad the
brainwashing of my dad that's right uh
and it's actually that's the website too
for that movie as well I don't have a a
trailer today now this is a little older
movie but other people pointed this out
to me in DMS and stuff because they went
and watched the game is up this is
another really good one to share with
your family it talks about a woman's dad
being brainwashed by Fox News
now I'm being brainwashed by Fox News so
maybe I'll pull the trailer and we can
play that
um you know maybe later this week next
week too but uh so go go watch both
those it's it's very it's worth watching
but not only that it's worth sharing uh
with your family and again not just your
your family that agrees with you maybe
your family who are Trump supporters or
family members who have family members
who were delusional we're here now on
Facebook horse paced eating
[ __ ]
so check those out um it's super
important that we give these people an
off ramp that's how we're going to get
through this but uh the most important
thing that you can do right now right
now is go vote and make sure and maybe
this gives you a point of engagement
right maybe this gives you a point of
Engagement with someone
maybe someone who's undecided doesn't
know not real sure maybe show them these
films I don't know maybe that's a point
of Engagement I don't know maybe maybe
it's a friend of yours a colleague yeah
a fellow parishioner at your church I
don't know maybe someone else at the PTA
maybe maybe and maybe this again this
this
particular film or these films uh the
game is up movie or the brainwashing of
my dad can help
engage and move it in that direction so
they'll make sure they vote
and then they get three other people
to encourage them encourage them to vote
as well okay everybody we got we got
some clips to get to
um we got some Herschel Herschel Walker
how many more abortions did this Gap pay
for I guess that's the the question
everyone's going to be asking over the
next
10 days everyone let's let's go it surf
the Tweety tweets and the trend Trends
you guys ready to surf for the [ __ ] list
Roundup start countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Michaels podcast we have reached the
part of the show called the [ __ ] list
Roundup where we round up all the Tweety
tweets and trendy Trends you know we do
not we do not [ __ ] around here we make
sure sunlight is the best disinfectant
here on the Tony Michaels podcast and we
got several
several ridges I'd like to show you look
at that that's kind of like a mirror
image right did you know we brought
Kansas on Twitter we broadcast this [ __ ]
on Twitter now a lot of people just
clicked the link here I'll show you I'll
show you a secret
a lot of people figure this out you see
this up here let me make this bigger
[ __ ] this is the actual broadcast right
now
but here see here it says Herschel
Walker pays for more abortions question
mark
um and then we have all the the tweeting
Trends in there that potential topics
that we're going to talk about today
which I and then we might make it to
most of these and then you and then we
got the two links Tony Michaels dot live
you can go watch it there or the YouTube
channel most people click this YouTube
link they click this YouTube link right
here and that's how they get to the show
that's how we got more people on uh
YouTube they don't watch on Twitter
Twitter sucks because you can't [ __ ]
chat with each other used to can't know
more I don't know why I don't know why
they do that I know it [ __ ] sucks
well whatever they want to do it's
Twitter you know I mean we're going to
talk about Elon today probably
speaking to Twitter but YouTube YouTube
The Links right there so when I post
this on my page you can go to the
YouTube you can always find the YouTube
link I sometimes I people point this out
hey man you didn't put the YouTube link
yeah I forgot I forgot you ever forget I
forgot but uh most time it's there
um again here's the the tile from today
boar abortions this [ __ ] guy really
is anyone surprised by this
that he paid for another abortion I'm
not hell I asked that question when the
first one came about
I was like how many more are we gonna
have
I figured there'd be more I don't know
so we'll get to the Herschel Walker
story but I want to show you this um
this uh ad that Kaylee mcenany and Blake
Masters delivered for Democrats
no I'm dead serious I mean they
they think what they're saying is going
to discourage people like you to vote
right
in this and this is a perfect ad for any
Democrat to run anywhere and it's just
their own words you don't have to
[ __ ] edit it
you don't have to put a thing in front
or thing behind and who to vote for
whatever you just play this [ __ ] clip
and it's only 21 seconds long this is
the perfect Democratic ad
he's [ __ ] fascist saying the [ __ ]
they're saying right in this video
I mean it it's Insanity all you got to
do is listen to these two chuckle heads
and go vote listen
stake on November 8th
everything literally everything the
whole constitutional republic remember
the Democrats tell us what they're going
to do if they get a senate majority
show the whole constitutional republic
is at risk yeah you God damn right if
you're if a fascist nazi like Blake
Masters here gets in charge of anything
absolutely anything yeah it's gonna be a
[ __ ] [ __ ] show
and he's gonna try to tear down our
democracy because he's a traitor he's an
insurrectionist he's a he's a Trumper
he's an election denier he doesn't like
democracy and he even calls it a
constitutional republic because he can't
he doesn't want to say the word they
don't even democracy is a bad word to
these [ __ ] wonder why
shocks to suck Blake Blakey but listen
to what he says what Democrats are gonna
do see if you can spot the thing that
you wouldn't go vote for
listen
right bye bye filibuster that means
Biden might be able to get his agenda
through
oh my God you mean if we vote for Kelly
in Arizona
Democrats all over the country that will
break the filibuster say it ain't so
all right yeah that sounds great okay
and so
mark one Blake Masters is encouraging
people to go vote if they want the
filibuster smashed up okay well I don't
think that's gonna work out for him
let's keep continuing you think one
katanji brown Jackson on the Supreme
Court is bad how about 10 more by this
time next year
whoa whoa did you hear that did you hear
that they they think we're gonna change
the Supreme Court
to make sure that I don't know they're
not taking away [ __ ] rights from
women
or anyone else in this country that has
constitutional [ __ ] rights in this
country
Blake Masters thinks you're gonna go
vote for Republican to make sure that
the Democrats I don't know preserve
rights
and put put the smartest [ __ ] people
on the Supreme Court 10 of them hails to
the yeah
we're gonna break the filibuster so we
can get an agenda pass voting rights
codify row and get 10 Supreme Court
Justices Blake Masters boy you are
really really tempting me
to not only encourage three people to
vote God damn I didn't just get five or
six people to encourage them to vote and
encourage them to get five or six
instead of three this sounds great let's
keep going Blake said stake on November
8th
that's it that's all that's all you
gotta show you see that let's play it
one more time let's play One More Time
set stake on November 8th
everything literally everything the
whole constitutional republic remember
the Democrats tell us what they're going
to do if they get a senate majority
right bye bye filibuster that means
Biden might be able to get his agenda
through yep you think one katanji brown
Jackson on the Supreme Court is bad
Fantastic Four by this time even better
so just play this I don't know if you
just want to you know retweet this play
it as the best Democratic ad that you
could possibly have I mean what more do
you need than Blake Masters telling you
what he's telling you here
who the [ __ ] is against this [ __ ] are
you [ __ ] me
what what
no okay someone um
someone pointed out that and I'm gonna
I'm not gonna play all this because
Jesus it's [ __ ] hilarious someone
pointed out that John fetterman had
trouble with some words on stage and
when I mean someone I mean the
Republicans made fun of him
for not being able to say words on stage
kind of funny it's kind of funny I don't
know because maybe there's another guy
who's done that a lot and he hadn't had
a stroke apparently but let's listen for
Europe the Nazis the invasion of
Normandy
and the liberalization of Europe a
brilliant star shown in the East Wise
Men traveled far really big
beneficiaries whole state to be a stank
sailor poor criminal okay I got another
a sanctuary okay that's enough listen if
you want to watch two minutes of just
hilarity and I think I watched this
three or four times yesterday because it
is [ __ ] hilarious it just goes on and
on and on and on on and on and on of
course there's millions of cases of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] box
cramming together words and and
absolutely not saying [ __ ] we're the
damn
just like I do I I [ __ ] up words all the
time all the time I don't I mean I but I
don't but I don't go and [ __ ] tell
someone who's had a goddamn stroke
who damn near died over it who's
standing on stage still fighting for
Pennsylvania because he's getting his
words mixed around a bit because he has
auditory issues from the stroke which is
only short term
and the dude's still standing still
fighting still talking not [ __ ]
backing down that's something that's
someone I want fighting for me if I was
in Pennsylvania for damn sure
not these [ __ ] stank ass can't shoot
Sanctuary not these stank ass
Republicans okay let's let's move on the
reason why I can't play that old clip to
be honest with you is it's a Daily Show
clip and when when you play a Daily Show
clip they put a copyright strike on it
now you can challenge it and it's a big
[ __ ] mess
so I don't play much of them
and I just retweet them so you can so
you can go see them uh speaking of a
great video
a Midas Touch you know we're we're
affiliated mindsets we brought gas from
the Midas touch Facebook page everybody
we do some of their their live shows we
post up bone end of the week every
Friday over there on the Midas touch
Network
we replay it over there they put out an
ad yesterday Trump is scared you do you
remember last weekend
when Nancy Pelosi said that he was too
much of a [ __ ] to come and show up and
testify oh my God how sweet was that but
minus touch put together just as good of
a clip it's called hashtag Trump is
scared here's the end what's the matter
Donald the January 6 committee
subpoenaed you and you're not going to
show you said you're such a strong man
you aren't a coward are you you aren't
guilty are you are you that afraid of
Liz Cheney they say you threw hamburgers
at the wall well here supporters know
you would never waste a good hamburger
oh please won't you come testify Donald
unless we're scared Midas Touch is
responsible for the content of this
advertising oh God damn brutal
brutal my mind is touching what's the
matter Donald uh it's a great video
Jordy had it here he says hi Trump is is
Trump is scared as trending 10 in the
United States of America of course they
got it trending right
oh here we go
um
and Texas Paul tweeted something about
uh a Spam cookbook
so we got the uh spam cookbook going I
don't know if you guys watched
yesterday's show and you should go watch
it and I think I'm gonna put it on the
Texas Paul playlist we had a Texas Paul
playlist he was there for almost the
entire show he normally I cut it out and
put it on its own but he was there for
the entire show yesterday like oh the
whole thing I mean after the a block my
my 30 minute
um crazy rant that I do in the front he
was there for the rest of the show so
and yeah oh hey you know what I forgot
about this lucky here Laura Windsor says
coming soon from Phoenix Arizona and new
Under current collaboration with
comedian Walter Masterson we know Walter
here no Walter is a friend of the show
I've actually I've actually been on his
live stream where he uh he trolls q and
honors it's hilarious I was on a stream
one time it's hilarious but um hey Ed
that Lauren goes on to say we tell
candidates that we're shooting oh my God
we're shooting illegals who cross the
southern border into our Ranch
stay tuned for their responses so in
other words they're trying to bait these
candidates
after they tell them they're they're
trying to shoot illegals when they're
crossing the southern border on their
Ranch
I guess she's gonna post what they
showed I don't know someone can someone
send me a link for this if um
um if if this video already exists I
forgot about this I posted this
yesterday I retweeted this I was like I
don't want to forget this you know
that's what I do a lot of times
most of my retweets
are to show you on the show
that's it's a lot of my show prep and
sometimes I just like what it is
and sometimes I'm using it for the show
that's why I retweet it because I'm
gonna I'm gonna use it on the show I'm
gonna show it to you
so and that big secret big huge secret
if you want to know what I'm going to
talk about on the show just go look at
my Twitter feed that's probably what
we're gonna that's probably the vidges
we're gonna we're gonna look at oh
speaking of videos and speaking of a
traitor
here's Mark Meadows
Where Have You Been Margie where you
been Marky Mark you've been hiding
you've been you've been you've been
flipping on people and grand juries is
that what you've been doing
is that what you've been doing snitching
you snitching fool you snitching some
[ __ ] I bet you gave all your [ __ ]
test messages for all your [ __ ]
burners didn't you didn't you son of a
[ __ ] you did Marky Mark look at this
[ __ ] on Trader TV News Network
hmm I bet he's gonna try to get
Redemption here let's listen to what
Mark's plan is
if they start to see that it's more of
the same get along uh go along kind of
politics uh it will not bode well in
2024. and so I can tell you we're
working here at the conservative
Partnership institute along with so many
conservative members to say we want to
have a boot camp the minute they get
elected where they come to Washington DC
and instead of trying to find time to
find the bathroom no Jesus Christ
you hear what he's gonna do
he's gonna get a boot camp holy [ __ ]
they're gonna train the SS
they're gonna train the brown shirts
when I was the essay I guess
they're gonna train their uh their Elite
their Elite group of political militants
in a boot camp
they're gonna train them up to be
traitors holy [ __ ] they're not even
saying they're not even they're not even
trying anymore
to keep quiet about what they're trying
to do they're telling you they're saying
it out loud what they're gonna do
they're not even going to give these
members to get elected time enough to
[ __ ] find the bathrooms in the
building what they're gonna do is
brainwash them and force them into their
agenda
their fascist agenda and that agenda is
to overturn our democracy so that way
they don't go to [ __ ] jail for their
crimes that's why they want him in power
again
and I'm talking about you Margie mark
you're you think
that if Trump becomes president he's
Gonna Save You same way Steve Bannon
same way Roger Stone same way Stuart
Rhodes
the founder of The Oath Keepers same
rate Enrique tario founder of The Proud
boys [ __ ] domestic terrorist
they
wanted Trump to be president to save
them
and they're willing to train up a whole
new group group of Traders Ah that's
what we'll do just just get us a whole
another group of treaters yeah
oh here's another thing that kind of
went unnoticed Kyle had it though Kyle
Chaney if you're not filing Kyle God
damn what are you doing you're not doing
the Twitter thing right he's always
dropping he's a legal correspondent
I think he's the senior correspondent
let's let's check it out here
senior of legal Affairs reporter at
Politico but Kyle is always on top of
this stuff judge Howe has docketed my
October 18th request to unseal records
related to Donald Trump's secret flight
excuse me secret fight against a flight
fight I get this
Sanchez said Trump fart Trump fart Trump
farts won yesterday versus Blaine I keep
wanting to say Trump farce one because
that's what everyone was deeming it
Donald Trump's secret fight against the
January 6
grand jury investigation
so he's trying to unseal those records
for the grand jury which I'm assuming is
probably the one that's really fighting
hard looking hard at the uh State
elector scheme
nah boy it really it feels like to me
that's the probe if there's gonna be one
that's really gonna rock
the underbelly of Maga
it's the state elector scheme it's not
just smearing [ __ ] on the walls at the
capitol or seditious conspiracy it's the
state elector's scheme because they were
sending messages and they had all kinds
of
[ __ ] evidence [ __ ] evidence
okay well I have did anyone find that
video did we find the video for the uh
Lauren did she post that yet let's see
no I don't see it there I want to play
that video If Lauren's got it let's just
go to Lauren's account see if she got it
dude
I want to see this
if we got the um the the video here now
Lauren does a great job nope doesn't
look like doesn't look like it's dropped
yet
I wonder when she's gonna drop that
anyone know I'm looking at her page here
let me show you you Didi there we go uh
here's Lauren's page
um
so she doesn't have it doesn't appear
that she has
anything dropping yet as far as videos
because here's the post I retweeted
it says coming soon
coming soon
so um I think um
I think um well maybe today I don't know
maybe today it'll drop
should I message Lauren and say hey
when are we gonna get this this video we
want this video
Tony Michaels is looking for the goddamn
video
for the for the show he's on his own
today he doesn't have Gabe Sanchez
helping him so he needs he needs plenty
of content plenty of video to play we're
at the top of the hour
we're at the top of the hour
one hour in I'm just getting started
let's do this give me a second let's
take a quick break when we come back
we'll do more on a [ __ ] list Roundup
right after these messages
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
we're serving the Tweety Tweets in the
trendy Trends right now and the [ __ ]
list Roundup
[Music]
do not forget
not forget to go
um follow us on Twitter
at Tony Michaels pod super important so
you can vote for bonehead of the week
you know every single Friday today's
Thursday
but every single Friday we do bone of
the week so we will release the bone end
of the week Pole
tonight
and you get a chance to vote
for bone end of the week and tomorrow in
the second hour of the Tony Michaels
podcast approximately at this time me
and my co-host Gabe Sanchez who tomorrow
will be in an undisclosed deep State CIA
uh location we don't want to give it
away
you know he's a Fed so we can't really
give that stuff away that
that information is ridiculous
you remember did you see this yesterday
in this [ __ ] video about
oh
Texas say it again Texas Paul went to
Washington DC and Allison I don't know
who the [ __ ] this is
she uh claims he's with the CIA
apparently
um
uh he didn't know it
I guess I guess you don't have to know
that you're in the CIA to be in the CIA
you should Claim Texas Paul as part of
the CIA because um I don't know he posts
videos on Midas Touch he's on the Midas
touch Network every once in a while so
he's somehow part of the CIA and there's
some kind of rigged algorithm I don't I
have no idea so but but uh Gabe Sanchez
is not here today because he is maybe
he's applying for the ca maybe that's
what it is I don't know [ __ ]
now these [ __ ] chuckleheads they make
they make up so much [ __ ] [ __ ]
so much [ __ ] [ __ ] they make this
stuff up
they say all kinds of crazy ass stupid
[ __ ] that doesn't even make any sense
most of it not even coupled to reality I
mean you would think you would think
that they would tide a few of them with
a little breadcrumbs to reality nope
nope
not Tethered to reality at all this
Allison with oan thinking that Texas
Paul went to the White House because a
rigged algorithms and the CIA but that's
where Gabe Sanchez is too I mean if you
believe that Texas ball is there you got
to believe that Gabe Sanchez is you know
that there too maybe he's auditioning
for this yeah I don't know how it works
I don't know how the CIA works we just
are the CIA because we're you know part
of the liberal left
the cabal
ah you [ __ ] dummies
uh how how how do you deal with these
people really
how can you deal with the stupid I don't
know I just I can't figure it out
because I believe that there's certain
actors out there like Tucker Carlson he
knows what he's saying it's [ __ ] he
knows what he's saying is is Putin's
little fantasy land fantasy wet dream
he knows it's Russian propaganda he even
says it that it's people are saying I'm
saying Russian propaganda yeah you are
dummy he knows it
I'm not real sure if Allison knows or
not if if
Texas ball is part of the CIA
I'm dead serious I think she actually
believes that [ __ ]
I don't know maybe she read it on some
kind of cute and on horse Pace Facebook
post or something I I don't know I I how
am I supposed to know where they get
this [ __ ]
pull this [ __ ] out of their ass
whoo baby okay let's go back to the
Tweety tweets here ah elon's trending
why is Elon trending has he does he did
he buy Twitter yet nope sure didn't
still hasn't bought Twitter and the deal
uh closed deadline is looming I guess he
showed up at the uh the headquarters and
[ __ ] employees from Twitter were
tweeting it out like they were excited
about it
the [ __ ] out of here you're not excited
[ __ ] you ain't gonna have a job that's
what he said
and he's trying to torch the deal all
the way to The Bitter End I'm sure this
morning he's in the Twitter headquarters
trying to torch the deal just like Kanye
West can't get a meeting in the [ __ ]
the Skechers office
you ever met that Kanye West
says all kinds of anti-Semitic [ __ ] into
a microphone
he doesn't understand the freedom of
speech that you can say all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] Kanye but there's
consequences to your speech that's how
it works
so he leans into the microphone and he
says I can sue you ain't the automatic
[ __ ] and Adidas can't do nothing and
Adidas dropped his ass dropped him
like a [ __ ] bag habit cut him down
like a fresh cut tree
done
he's no longer a billionaire over it
so dude packs his suitcase
gets his sh his Yeezy shoe samples and
decides he's gonna go to Skechers
and I I don't know
um
exactly who owns Skechers but
people been people been uh um putting in
cameras it may be it may be Jewish some
Jewish people that have owned Skechers
for a while but apparently he went in
the schedules headquarters and didn't
make it past the lobby they kicked him
out on his ass they escorted him out
immediately
Skechers of course you know I I I don't
have anything against Skechers
I I mean
I used to have a pair of steel toed
Skechers shoes that's the only pair of
Skechers that I've ever owned I worked
in a warehouse a long time ago
and you had to wear steel-toed boots and
I had a pair of boots and a pair of
Skechers steel-toed shoes
they're kind of weird but yeah that's
the only pair of Skechers that I've
owned
I think don't quote me on that I am a
dad I am a dad and I am a white dude so
there is a possibility that I have worn
our own more more than just that pair of
Skechers that's the one that sticks out
in my brain
but they kicked Yeezy
and Kanye
out on his ass when he went to Skechers
to try to pimp his anti-semitic shoe
line I guess
but Elon because you know this is the
thing the Republicans love these
characters they love Trump and he's a
pile of [ __ ] he's such a [ __ ] loser
he loses the the popular vote in 16
actually gets trounced in 2020. his
candidates get trounced in his midterm
his candidates are going to get trounced
in this midterm because I'm very
optimistic that you are going to engage
in your democracy
so they they tweet Trump and then and
then they tweet Elon and then they tweet
Kanye I'm serious it's probably in this
thread let's go in this thread I almost
bet you that that [ __ ] image lives in
this thread that people are pointing
that out I bet you oh look look at this
look
this guy look at this guy when did he
tweet this
Gabe Sanchez I tweeted about about an
hour ago
so he tweeted at the top of the show so
he's probably listening I would imagine
maybe he sent this to me but I'm just
happening upon it
Elon Musk Chief [ __ ]
he may have changed it I don't know if
you've seen Elon Musk changed his
his title to Chief twit and um
Sanchez apparently has changed it to
Chief [ __ ] no well that makes sense
that's about right
our co-host living on the show even
though he's not on the show
um
okay well he's got to show up for the
Deep State CIA
um convention today I don't again I'm
trying to figure out exactly where he's
at okay let's see if we can find this
image I know it's in this I know it's in
this thread no question see there's our
broadcasters in the thread and it did it
I know there's going to be an image of
this Republicans tweeting this [ __ ] in
here
It's gotta be gotta be Maybe I'm Wrong
holy [ __ ] am I wrong nah I'm never wrong
no I can't be it's not I'm telling you
up I might you know what here's the
thing we just go to photos see a little
tab up there you just go to photos and
that gives you all the media that's in
that thread
and a screenshot of the Tweet because
I'm not sure what account it's from I
know it's a republican uh Congressional
account I think it's a senate Republican
someone help me out here see this is why
Gabe's ninjas needs to be on the damn
show
when I'm sitting here yamping my trap
he's looking up this [ __ ] trying to find
these things
you see why he's so important why he's
so cried so crucial that he be here
on the show every single weekday Monday
through Friday
no he's got to go off and be
interviewing for the CIA when he just he
doesn't even know Gabe Sanchez doesn't
even know
that we don't have to apply for the CAA
we're automatically in the CIA we're
automatically in the CIA here is a good
picture though
I want to stop on this one
and someone edited this photo obviously
that the Tweet chief or the twit chief
and here's Elon Musk at the Twitter
headquarters this morning drinking what
appears to be coffee what do you think
kind of
what do you think kind of liquid is in
that thing
hmm I don't know
I wonder if he traded a horsey for it
where in the [ __ ]
is this damn okay see it's making a liar
out of me this whole thread
it's how it works on Twitter though when
you're looking for something sometimes
you just gotta search it
sometimes you just gotta search it you
just gotta type it in
I will type it in right now
here we go
search search search
there it is see I knew I had to get it I
knew I'd get it
I gotta sneeze like a son [ __ ] and I
don't want to sneeze into the microphone
so I'm trying
to prevent sneezing okay let's go to the
screen okay here's the um
here it is house Judiciary
g-o-p it's the house Judiciary Committee
they tweeted on 10 6 22 at 8 05 p.m this
was in the evening I don't know maybe
someone was drunk
maybe I don't know you think they delete
this [ __ ] though because it was
tweeted from an iPhone Kanye Elon Trump
I don't know if there's a particular
reason for this order
I don't know maybe it maybe it is maybe
it is how they're going to be canceled
in that order Kanye canceled
no longer a billionaire
Elon maybe he's next canceled no longer
a billionaire I don't know maybe man
beats me Trump's never been a
billionaire so maybe that doesn't make
him a lot of logical sense because
Trump's last right
I mean are they trying to tell us
something here they're always trying to
[ __ ] project this [ __ ]
maybe that's what they're trying to do
here I don't know I can't figure it out
but everyone keeps pointing out that
they tweeted these three names as if
that's like who they wanted on the
Judiciary Committee Kanye Elon Trump
they love these guys they love these
[ __ ] boxes I mean they are their [ __ ]
boxes
they are their [ __ ] boxes now you are
you are them Kanye Elon and Trump year
ear fascist
whoo
anti-semitic fascist uh so here if you
if you need more evidence here's a
here's a white shot of it
from the white background instead of the
dark background Kanye Elon Trump from
the house Judiciary GOP 805 p.m August
or October Jesus Christ October 6 2022.
I'm suffering from a bit of a hangover
too it's that's possibility uh Twitter
for iPhone Twitter for iPhone
so it's definitely tweeted from an
iPhone
at at night night
hmm maybe they were drinking like I had
been I don't know it's a possibility
it's a possibility
okay let's um and so Elon is not gonna
buy Twitter he still hasn't bought
Twitter so that's on that PayPal is
trending what the [ __ ] why is Paypal
trending uh oh something wrong with
PayPal I don't know I don't know
um looks like they're donating to
Ukraine breaking
uh PayPal has reintroduced their policy
of taking 2500 from your account if they
deem you spread misleading information
hmm
I I don't know I don't know what's going
on with PayPal something's going on with
PayPal
oh here we go is this the right wing
freaking out is that what this is
yes it is all these bunch of [ __ ] ah
here we go this is this must be a great
story
I don't know if you know this piece of
[ __ ]
he's the president of Judicial Watch fat
checker
and he's even got expert in quotes
Donald Trump Jr doing the air quotes
they don't know how they work
expert
oh [ __ ] he's got in there quotes this
piece of [ __ ]
um he tweets alerts not only has paid
balance due to 2500 fine for misleading
information
but it says it can hold all monies in
your account for up to six months if
reasonably needed to protect against the
risk of liability if you have violated
RX acceptable use policy I don't know
why
sounds like people are freaking out
because PayPal is gonna punish people
for spreading around lies oh man ain't
that about a [ __ ]
the right wing can't under listen
you people keep claiming your free
market capitalist and you want to tell
PayPal what the [ __ ] they can and can't
do
Tom Fenton
you claim that your Judicial Watch you
claim that you're an expert and a fact
Checker here's a [ __ ] fact
PayPal gets to do what they want to do
inside the law dummy
and they can tell you you can [ __ ] off
you can't be spreading around
misinformation with your [ __ ] account
or we'll take it from you it's in the
it's in the [ __ ] thing when you do
the business and the thingy thing when
you agree and you sign you say yeah I'll
do that
foreign
people are [ __ ] dumb and of course
they're gonna be like ah boycott PayPal
boycott now they're socialist they're
the left
it's called capitalism what do you want
what the [ __ ] do you want
just like Adidas telling Kanye to [ __ ]
off
it's their right they get to do that he
doesn't get to he doesn't get to drag
them into the defamation and the
anti-Semitism speech that he has to
destroy their brand he doesn't get to do
that they get to protect their brand
from his dumb ass
and really frankly you know a lot of
people were upset about Adidas and
really I think were they messed up to be
straightforward and transparent is they
didn't release a statement saying hey we
are going to change our relationship
with Kanye we just got to figure that
out because they had huge contracts I
mean they probably had room full of
lawyers trying to figure out how to undo
this in a way that Kanye can't sue them
because really honestly there's so much
money involved in these in these shoes
globally that
and the brand in general not just the
shoes but the brand in general
that if Kanye was able to sue them they
would really be [ __ ] so they're going
to protect their interest unlike Kanye
saying anti-semitic racist [ __ ] into a
microphone and then daring them not to
do something he not only said
anti-semitic [ __ ] folks he leaned into
the microphone and said Adidas can't do
[ __ ] about it
yeah they can just the same way PayPal
can do something about it Tom
it's the same thing you [ __ ] dummies
why don't you get the freedom of speech
you don't get it you don't get that
you're free to say what you want but
you're not free from the consequences
I mean you can say all kinds of vile
stupid [ __ ] Kanye said is said
defamatory [ __ ] about George Floyd and
his family is now going to sue him for
that defamation
because you can say lies Tom you could
say [ __ ] lies buddy
but that doesn't mean you don't get too
[ __ ] have consequences for those lies
you stupid [ __ ]
just like Kanye West absolutely lying
about George Floyd now rather he
believes it or not
rather he believes it or not
that's going to be up for the courts to
the side right
if they actually have
a court case and this goes to court for
the George Floyd family they don't
settle out of court because I think
they're suing him for 250 million
dollars I think is what the the the the
lawsuit currently is
but Tom dude
either claim that you're a fact Checker
and you know facts or don't man
because the expert in quotes makes sense
now
it really does make sense it makes sense
like not dollars and cents but you know
the kind that comes out of your brain
this guy's a [ __ ] bonehead
oh PayPal's punishing me for my for my
speech I mean
that's how it works dude okay
um
let's see let's let's uh make sure this
guy knows that this tweet sucks your
Tweet sucks man
oh and by the way it was on the Tony
Michaels podcast boom
learn how to capitalist if you want to
be a capitalist Tom [ __ ] idiot okay
that's why PayPal's turning let's go
back to the Tweety tweets Andre the
Giant is trending do you guys remember
Andre the Giant he was humongous he's in
a couple of movies and it did it Hatch
Act is trending oh they're freaking out
Ron Clane may have got his hands slapped
over the handshake why do we still have
the Hatch Act really frankly why why is
this still a thing why why are we making
government officials track down the
hatchback they didn't do a goddamn thing
about the [ __ ] Trump Administration
officials breaking the son of a [ __ ]
four and five times a [ __ ] day on
every goddamn Trader News Network there
was
the [ __ ] out of here just why do we even
have this thing either do it or don't
just get rid of the [ __ ]
honestly get rid of it I mean yeah we do
we want the protection but if they're
not gonna do anything [ __ ] it
maybe this is another goddamn reason why
we need to have those 10 katanji Brown
Jackson's on the Supreme Court
and make sure that we carve out the
filibuster so that we can actually make
consequences for the [ __ ] Hatch Act
I'm not I'm not opposed to Ron Clane
receiving [ __ ] consequences for the
Hatch Act if he violated it and
especially if it was malicious fine
whatever [ __ ] punish him
but to expect to [ __ ] and complain that
you're gonna make Ron claim here's
here's the report
here's a report white house chief of
staff Ron Clane has received a warning
from the office of special counsel for
violating the Hatch Act he used a
official account to retweet a message
that included get your Democrats deliver
merch today
so he used a White House official
account to send out something about
Democrat merch
and it's a violation of the Hatch Act
which they give him a warning of course
everyone oh my God block him up put him
in prison I'm sure Tucker Carlson will
do 40 minutes tonight on why Ron glane
should be towed it off to gitmo and hang
because he violated the Hatch Act and
he'll forget all about every [ __ ] one
of the hatchback violations that every
single almost every single Trump
Administration official did on his show
and on his Network the [ __ ] out of here
did we are we really giving a [ __ ] about
the Hatch Act today is that what we're
doing get the [ __ ] out of here we got
more important [ __ ] to do way more
important [ __ ] and that's why I show you
this that's why I want you to be [ __ ]
pissed off about this stuff
I'm telling you this is a waste of
[ __ ] time
to be to be tweeting about the Hatch Act
or be talking to [ __ ] buying into
this [ __ ] distraction about the
handshake because guarantee you a
hundred [ __ ] bucks Tucker Carlson is
gonna say some dumb [ __ ] tonight on Fox
news about the Hatch Act
and it's gonna be dumb because it's
gonna be hypocritical as [ __ ] because I
guarantee you the [ __ ] that he's gonna
accuse Ron clean of and the punishment
that he should receive they're gonna
pull a [ __ ] clip of him
allowing someone to do the same goddamn
stupid thing on his show
almost guarantee it I don't even need to
know
and the reason why is because these
people are [ __ ] [ __ ] boxes
so who gives a [ __ ] Ron Clayton got a
warning you know the difference between
Ron Clane getting a warning you want to
know the difference between Ron could
Tucker you wanna know the difference
between Ron clay getting a warning
from the office of special counsel for
the Hatch Act violation is he'll [ __ ]
he won't do it again
he won't overtly violate the Hatch Act
again in this way by tweeting from an
official account [ __ ] about Democrats
merch he won't do it again they didn't
give a [ __ ] and they I mean the fascist
[ __ ] out of here with this nonsense okay
let's go back to this is the Tweety
tweets and trendy Trends I got to work
with though folks I don't know what to
tell you the handshake is trending at
number 11. on politics it's trending
okay let's see we're um we're at almost
at the bottom of the hour I'm gonna take
a brick break here soon see if I can get
this sneeze out of the sneeze and I want
to sneeze into the microphone so maybe
we'll take a break here um here soon and
we'll um see if I can
I could sneeze
I'm holding it back like a [ __ ]
I don't even tell
um 21 turning is uh gets 2024 what in
the actual see this is more nonsense
I saw this when I didn't even click into
it though I had to put it on the trend
thing for the
because we might talk about it what the
[ __ ] do I get the [ __ ] out of here what
a waste of time what a waste of space
this these two [ __ ] words are not
words the word and the year
Mac ants 2024 what a waste Jesus what a
what a waste of my time in your time
already okay let's move on down let's
see what we get that run out of Politics
on the list so this is what happens now
let's refresh see if anything's moving
up the list
elon's still at number three PayPal's
number four
um did anything else pop up on the list
this is how this is how I serve Twitter
do you guys use the trending topics to
serve Twitter or do you use the search
bar or the Home tab there's also the
Home tab you know you get this right up
here this um some people call it the
lobby
you know I got the home button here yeah
I I sometimes go there I sometimes but
most time I live in the uh the trends
I want to know what's trending and
here's the for you
the for you this is it's been a long
time since we then since we did the
shitless Roundup like this I used ears
for anyone out there listening who
hasn't been a listener for a long time I
know a lot of you have been here for
several months how the [ __ ] list was
born I'll tell you this let me tell you
this before we go to a sneeze break here
because I'm really I'm really [ __ ]
holding it back
um
the uh the shitless Roundup was born I
used to do a twitch stream because the
podcast was only once a week it was only
on Wednesdays and then I did a twitch
stream every day and it was kind of a
haphazard right we didn't and then
finally I scheduled it where I did at
the same time every day and we did the
shitless Roundup that's what it was the
twitch stream was just the [ __ ] list
Roundup that's what we did people would
come and they would watch on Twitter or
twitch and they watched the [ __ ] list
Roundup and I just surf Twitter that's
where it came from
that's the origin of the shitless
Roundup where we'd surf the Tweety
tweets and trendy Trends you know I say
at the end of every show I say Surf's Up
[ __ ] I used to say that
during the twitch Stream So now I say it
during the show because we do the [ __ ]
list Roundup but it's become a thing
that you just say at the end of the show
because everyone's typing it in anyways
everyone's there okay let's see what
else is trying oh twatter is trending it
must be uh Elon Captain Kangaroo is
trending I don't know what the hell
that's about uh let's see what else do
we have here but this is the For You tab
here and it gives you uh and you can
refresh this thing because it'll give
you and it gives you your if you got
your
your your location typed in it'll give
you like local news to like your state
uh grifting is trending oh I'm sure this
is about Trump
oh no it's that guy right now I don't
know maybe Trump Karen ah it's about
Maga
it's about manga grifting no [ __ ] you
don't say well I got the perfect
commercial for that everyone stick
around we're gonna go we're gonna go for
a sneeze break here see if I can sneeze
stick around don't go anywhere listen to
the commercial talking about grifting
we'll be back right after these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment we're
[Music]
to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
Shook and [ __ ] sneeze I tried
I tried the tricks you look into the
light
[Music]
you clear my throat
[Music]
and that'll help it's got a drink of
water
that's a [ __ ] when you gotta sneeze and
you got a microphone in front of you
and you know you know thousands of
people are watching and you kind of
[ __ ] sneeze
um someone pointed out that the uh the
PayPal story The reason why it's
trending is because these right Wingers
get it wrong oh who would have thought
who would have thought they got the
[ __ ] facts wrong even the fact
checker
Tom Benton got the [ __ ] facts wrong
what a bunch of dummies but you know the
thing is about PayPal is they could do
that they could probably they could do
that I mean again with this as long as
it's in the bounds of the law they can
do what they want
that's one problem with corporations
that we have is we don't have many
bounds for them sometimes that's one
reason why [ __ ] inflation is running
rampant
because we're not holding corporations
accountable not just not just for the
prices that they're jacking up on
consumers but the wages that they're not
paying their [ __ ] workers that are
trading labor that's right you trade
your labor to get your wage most times
when you work for an employer
and these corporations are not giving
you the inflated wage you deserve
even though they're inflating their
profits
so should we hold them accountable sure
we should have bounds that's I mean
again these these Maga Republicans don't
even know that they're making decent
Arguments for us
they're saying it out loud
maybe PayPal shouldn't yeah maybe PayPal
shouldn't do that I don't know I mean
maybe it's a good idea maybe it isn't
they just don't they don't [ __ ] think
about this in in the frame of hey this
is a democracy and we need to put people
in charge who are adults who can think
this through to make sure they're making
great decisions for our I don't know
country
even sometimes when they [ __ ] up when
they [ __ ] up bad
they can admit it and we can change it
we can do that sort of thing like in the
1990s when they passed a crime Bill Joe
Biden voted for it Joe Biden knows he
[ __ ] up he knows that he knows that
now definitely after seeing the results
of what that what that bill created
and he's tried to do what he can as the
power that he has now as president
that he didn't have then
but up till now
when he actually gave Federal pardons to
anyone with a possession of marijuana
charge
non-violent possession charge he gave
him pardons
so he's he's trying his best now he
can't just undo a bill he's a president
right like we don't want the president
to have that power
you don't want some [ __ ] buffoon you
know in case a buffoon gets in
never had that happen before wank
anybody else remember 2016
when a [ __ ] idiot got elected
president would you really want him to
have the Reigns of power to change
legislation [ __ ] no
see you don't want Joe Biden to have it
you don't want Barack Obama to have it
you don't want George W bush Bill
Clinton HW Brian Ray on and on the goes
and any future presidents that we have
you don't exactly want them to have
certain power autocratic powers
and we don't we're not an autocracy
we are democracy
so
stick to your principles figure out what
you believe Maga and then [ __ ]
believe it would you please it would be
it would be so much easier on the rest
of us if you [ __ ] picked out some
things that you believe in and just did
that instead of being all over the
[ __ ] map
the stupid map by the way okay let's see
what was I gonna what was I gonna go to
that we're 35 minutes into the second
hour communist is trending I'm not
[ __ ] your communist is trending
let's go into this let's go into this
thread see what's in here see what kind
of right Wingers are freaking out oh
here you go
here you go
more misinformation more [ __ ]
it's funny how on a day that that Elon
Musk visits
Twitter headquarters to be the commander
of Twitter if he shows up with the money
tomorrow which I doubt but if he shows
up with the money tomorrow it might it
might just be in the interest of
communist
in China
you ever think about that you want to
wonder why maybe some of these things
are trending today I don't know I'm not
saying ma'am but why can't we come up
with our own conspiracy theories crying
out loud
why not
now okay
handshake still trending oh New York
Post
New York Post has been hacked
why is that important
I don't know why is the New York Post
being
um
I I don't know
do they do they need to be hacked is it
to [ __ ] post [ __ ] that's real
is that what it is I don't know I mean
how am I supposed to know your post is
trash
I mean
trash trash okay let's go back to the
trends I'm gonna see if I can find
videos of Herschel Walker yeah he's not
trending anymore what the [ __ ] why isn't
Herschel Walker drinking that's crazy I
guess everyone's like yeah it's so what
he said he's paid for abortions this
isn't going to be the last time we're
gonna hear about this now Gloria Allred
um is uh I actually you know what this
is a great idea I want to play this
video holy [ __ ] this is a great video
um I I actually followed this this this
tick tocker long ago long before his
account blew up
um I knew I knew his account was so good
and his account is called damn it it
said Thomas I don't want to get it wrong
Thomas underscore
uh villain underscore Bishop I believe
that's what it is nah but I don't want
to get it wrong
and I can't see it very well here on the
screen but
this video here is a [ __ ] fantastic
video because he breaks down this
Herschel Walker thing listen to this
let's see if I can get the volume up
listen to this so USA Today
put out an opinion piece
and it's basically something I've been
saying all along
about Herschel Walker
you're seeing the annals of the
Republican brain
Herschel Walker is the perfect
representation for black people
without question
he is every stereotype that we have been
called for 40 50 60 [ __ ] years
every single one
and of course I had my mic muted
I'm just I'm just it listen today today
is is a rough day today is a rough day
it really is here
hello volume okay I paused it to tell
you that um Thomas his handle at Thomas
underscored the villain underscore
Bishop so I had it wrong
I had the handle wrong but make sure you
go file Thomas on Tick Tock if you are
on Tick Tock that's what I was trying to
say when I had my mic muted but that is
what you should go follow him and the
reason why I followed him almost
immediately when he first came on Dick
deck is the guy gives no [ __ ] he does
not hold back doesn't give a [ __ ] that's
what I liked about him hmm well let's
let's continue to listen again this
video is about three minutes long so I'm
gonna let you listen to the whole thing
here
absentee father check
abusive
check
illiterate
check
athletic
check
will listen to
what his Masters say
check
he's a perfect representation
and sadly
he might just win
he might just win
you see
black men like Fred Hampton and Huey P
Newton Malcolm X and Martin Luther King
at no point would they do the step and
fetch it for
for American society they weren't going
to do it
too much pride too much dignity too much
manliness for that to happen
but the racist tropes never went away
they never did we never confronted them
unless we confronted them in the black
community but we never confronted them
Nationwide society-wide
so they persisted
and to look at someone like Rafael
Warnock
who embodies the spirit of the Fred
Hamptons the Malcolm X's the Martin
Luther Kings
well how do you beat that
you beat it by putting somebody's so
polar opposite yet so acceptable because
he's under your banner that he might
just win
and they found it
lusting after white women check
he is everything we have ever been
called in society
I keep saying all along
if they find a picture of Herschel
Walker eating Chicken and watermelon you
will have inward bingo
and sadly he might win
so when people start talking to me about
how much we progressed as a society the
only thing I must say from this point
forward is look at Herschel Walker and
tell me you still believe that
so so it's time and I got my audio
straight now but it's time some people
are saying I can't do this without Gabe
listen I don't know if he's got control
from the CIA of my switchboard here of
how it's working or not but I I don't
know maybe I just haven't been doing a
good enough job for the the old deep
State CIA
but this is Thomas here is exactly
correct about the tropes about the
[ __ ] now listen when I was young
all the [ __ ] that he's saying all the
[ __ ] that he just said
that's what that that's was
institutionalized
That's Why Us
as white men especially and me and Texas
Paul has talked about this on the show
white men especially should speak out
against this this institutional racism
it's us that did this
and I don't mean us like personally
but it's set up institutionally for us
by us
and we have to uncouple this and the
best way to do it
the best way to get in a situation where
we can do this where we can accomplish
that
is to go [ __ ] vote because even
Thomas is very he's not he's not 100
sure that Herschel Walker is gonna lose
and it's no guarantee it's not a
guarantee that Herschel Walker's gonna
lose the only guarantee that there is
the only guarantee that there is is if
you vote or not
that's a guarantee
if you can guarantee that God damn it
I'm gonna do whatever it takes to go
vote I don't care what it takes I'm
gonna go vote and I'm gonna have my
legal ballot cast
then that is the guarantee that's it
that's it and you can encourage three
other people to guarantee that and them
to encourage three other people now you
know that um Herschel Walker the subject
of Thomas's video there
um has been accused again
have another abortion paying for another
abortion apparently he used cash this
time instead of a check and a Hallmark
card but the good liars put this sign
upset of a Herschel Walker rally which
you know I think this is helpful to
people it says welcome to the Herschel
Walker rally if you are here
rehearsal campaign speech
please form a line on the left
if Herschel got you pregnant and you are
here to collect money for an abortion
and you are here to collect money for an
abortion please form a line to the right
thank you
um this is the good liars posted this um
sign outside of a urgent Walker rally
here's where they we put this uh
uh put this up some helpful signs the
Herschel Walker rally so
[Music]
um
oh that's a good thing the good liars
are on the case how would anyone know
which line to stand in
at the Herschel Walker rally I mean
there's apparently a lot of people that
need to know which line to be in uh
Aaron Rupert is the um the clip from Fox
News listen to what Herschel says here
this is actually
we've heard this nonsense about how John
fetterman blah blah blah John Federman
can't put words together John fetterman
doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's talking
about and then you have this example
down in Georgia where Herschel Walker
it's the worst word salad in the world
it's even worse than Trump word it's
worse than my word salad most of the
time yeah I know I got a problem
I know it
I'll admit it though I don't give a [ __ ]
I'll admit it
I'll admit it
but Herschel I'm not a [ __ ] I'm not
running for a U.S Senate seat
I'm not running for a U.S Senate seat
Herschel Walker is but listen to what he
says so right now they would do whatever
they can and say whatever they can to
win Powerball for this seat but not on
my watch yeah I try to lie and I told
everyone this is a lie and it's not a
lie I'm here did you catch that I think
Gabe needs to do a what was that on this
what do you think listen they can try to
lie and I told everyone this is a lie
and it's not a lie I'm here
one more time
Gabe Sanchez definitely needs to do a a
what was that on this listen again
listen to what he says about it's a lie
and then the last one the line I told
everyone this is a lie and it's not a
lie I'm here I told everyone it's a lie
but it's not a I I don't know make it
make sense good luck I I really can't
figure this out I mean again
um let me see if I can find the um the
all red
actually here's even a better clip
here's here's the old lady G defending
this [ __ ] fool and you know they just
bury themselves and a bunch of Maga [ __ ]
like honestly they just taint themselves
listen but they're scared to death of
Herschel Walker because if Herschel
Walker becomes a republican maybe every
other young child in America of color
might want to be a republican that this
is you know Thomas was talking about a
trope
this this is a live this right here is a
live key look at a Trope right in front
of your [ __ ] face
where a white Southern Man
has to speak
for a black man
100 this is a Trope Lindsey Graham's
much better at speaking much better and
just just keep keep quiet keep quiet
black man I'll speak for you I'll tell
you what you're supposed to think I'll
say what you're supposed to say
right here that's this Trope right here
watch that's what they're trying to do
don't let them get away with it team
herschel.com I want the biggest night
for the Herschel Walker campaign to be
tonight
doubt me that's exactly what this Trope
is right here Thomas is spot on every
[ __ ] box that you have to check
for this [ __ ] Uncle Tom boom you got
it
that's right I said it
I don't give a [ __ ]
it's right before your eyes
see it that's that's why they're doing
this on Fox news they showing the white
people that Herschel Walker listens to
the white people
he does what Whitey tells him to do
that's what this is that's what the [ __ ]
this video is
that's what this [ __ ] is that's what
this clip is
doubt me
I bet you I bet you a lot of money
that there was a lot of white dudes
watching Fox News
at that moment and boy they were really
getting the Rocks off oh boy this is the
best thing ever
watching Lindsey Graham a southern white
man
tell the black man what the hell he's
gonna think and what the hell he's gonna
do and speaking for him
so much so that he sang his script
why he just sits and goes yes yes sir
yes sir
every [ __ ] box Thomas is right every
[ __ ] one of them
and people in Georgia should be pissed
that this lion sack of [ __ ] that they're
gonna let him [ __ ] run on a [ __ ]
major party ticket and have a chance to
win
because he does this [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
well don't let it happen Georgia
it's up to you okay let's I I would love
to stay on [ __ ] Lindsey Graham but I
want to get to the uh Gloria Allred clip
if I can find it here now of course that
Lindsey Graham Clips going around but
again that's exactly what Thomas was
talking about
it's exactly what the [ __ ] he was
talking about here's the Gloria Allred
press conference again a second woman
has come forward so originally there was
a woman who said hey he paid for an
abortion he sent me a 700 check in a
[ __ ] get well card
uh Herschel Walker is denying it the
card has his [ __ ] signature on it
it's his [ __ ] chick with his
signature it's it's [ __ ] his
and of course he's still denying that
[ __ ] which is not and then and then that
same person with the first abortion that
Herschel Walker paid for had to say you
look [ __ ] you know who I am
and maybe he doesn't know
I mean you know I surmise that way back
when maybe he doesn't know who these
women are that are accusing him he has
no idea he's paid for so many [ __ ]
abortions he doesn't [ __ ] know
has no idea has no idea which one is
which
but here is um lawyer Allred
um
and this woman apparently had an
abortion in a Dallas clinic
um and Gloria also holds up a a photo
now let me tell you something about all
red here's the thing
if she has one person
that has information about abortions
that Herschel Walker has paid for
then she has all of them
[Laughter]
oh boy okay let's let's listen
in April of 1993
our client learned that she was pregnant
she was surprised
she had been on birth control throughout
their entire relationship
when she told Mr Walker that she was
pregnant
he seemed shocked
she didn't know what to do
Mr Walker clearly wanted her to have an
abortion and convinced her to do so
our client alleges that Mr Walker gave
her cash to pay for the abortion
and that she went to a clinic in Dallas
Texas
however while she was at the clinic
she became overwhelmed with emotion
she could not go through with it and she
left the clinic in tears
when Mr Walker called that ushered her
to go back to the clinic with him the
next day
to go through with the abortion
the following day
Mr Walker drove her to the clinic
and waited in the parking lot for hours
until the abortion was completed and she
came out
okay so did you hear that and we're
getting close to the end of the show but
you know a lot of people said I'm crazy
in private and you know in public about
this abortion thing that you know where
this is headed
okay these these these forced birthers
who are forcing little little girls to
have babies who are forcing women to die
put their lives at risk
ramming babies
these same [ __ ] Herschel Walker
who claims to be pro-life and oh he he
lived me he's not gonna murder no babies
he forced this woman
to have an abortion
did you hear that did you hear that part
of the story
she didn't want to have one
but he pressured her
not only
is Herschel Walker out there paying for
abortions
when the women don't want one he's
trying to force them and in this
instance it seems like he was
[ __ ] there forcing her the entire
time now why is this important you ask
that's the whole point of the choice you
[ __ ] idiots that's the whole point of
giving people and women in particular
the liberty of their [ __ ] uterus and
their goddamn choices to their bodily
autonomy in a doctor's office
you piles of [ __ ] garbage that is why
it is so important not just not just
to make sure that the exception of Life
rape and incest is there but to make
sure that someone isn't [ __ ] forcing
them violating their civil rights by
pressuring them sitting outside in the
car waiting
pressuring her driving her there forcing
her to go
I'm telling you
here's what their plan is
and doubt me on this I mean you cannot
go vote and we can you know my
my predictions will play out
you don't want to get it to that point
trust me
what these fascists want is they don't
give a [ __ ] about the abortion they
don't give a [ __ ] about the abortion not
a single [ __ ] all that stuff is all
[ __ ] if you think Maga Republicans
have any principles left you are a dumb
[ __ ] they have no principles
it's not about abortion
nope not about the life of the baby not
about conception or when or when it's a
human when it's not they nope it's not
about any of that [ __ ] what trimester
late term I mean Jesus Christ they're
saying Democrats are aborting babies
after they're born that's not even a
thing that's called Murder you [ __ ]
idiots you can't abort a baby after it's
born it's now a baby you didn't abort it
but they don't give a [ __ ]
about the actual abortion or abortion
services in general
do you wanna know what it's about you
want me to tell you you already know
this you guys are smart
controlling the woman
that's what it's about 100 full stop
making sure that the woman does not have
rights
and using using her bodily autonomy to
take away her rights put her back where
she belongs in society
because you get you can get wrong tea
guaran God damn
[ __ ] tea
that if these Republicans get what they
want
and they ban abortion nationally
do you know what their next move is
to force women to have abortions
are you listening
I'm telling you
the fascists want to make it to where
they can force women to have an abortion
just like Herschel Walker pressure this
woman into having abortion
it's what they want they want full
control over someone else's Liberty
that's what it is
and men men if you don't hear this
[ __ ] story about Herschel Walker and
and want to absolutely dunk every single
[ __ ] Trump hump and moglodyte in the
[ __ ] trash in this election you're
not paying attention
this is the perfect example of why we
can't have these [ __ ] having any reins
of power because Herschel Walker doesn't
believe a goddamn word he says not a
goddamn word not a [ __ ] word because
if he really truly believed it if you
really truly believed it he would have
told us about this [ __ ] he would have
told us this is why I believe because I
did this because this happened that's
what he would tell you
but he didn't
he doesn't actually believe the [ __ ]
he wants
there to be no bodily autonomy for women
because he wants to control women that's
his thing that's his fetish it's obvious
sickening is disgusting but it is up to
you and not just the women out there to
defend their rights we as men have to
defend them for them too or they'll come
after hours hell they're going to come
after the woman's vote you don't think
they'll come after their vote
come on give me a break
it's the mogula dates you're talking
about okay everybody we have reached the
top of the second hour I appreciate you
guys sticking with me the whole time
even through trying to Snee
trying to sneeze today the whole [ __ ]
time I still haven't sneezed I don't
have to sneeze as bad now I still got
the the tickle and the nose you know you
know what I mean
but but I I haven't sneezed yet into the
microphone and then I had a hoop blah
with my microphone you know I ain't got
my executive producer here Gabe Sanchez
trying to look for links trying to find
the veggies to show you guys I
appreciate you hanging with me today
it's been a wonderful day to hang with
you on this Thursday don't forget to
subscribe to the YouTube channel you're
not going to want to miss the bonehead
of the week pole it'll be right there on
YouTube this evening whenever we
whenever we decide who the bone is see
that's the thing everyone's like hey you
haven't got the bonehead yet and
sometimes we're waiting to see
who it is like because there are so many
of them and they're I mean it's like a
waterfall of bonehead sometimes that
we're waiting till late into the evening
to figure out who the bonehead for
tomorrow is going to be right um
hell I don't know maybe Matt Getz comes
up with something maybe Jim Jordan Rand
Paul is a definite shoe-in for a last
minute bonehead of the week trust me but
we will post that tonight on YouTube and
also on Twitter so go follow us on
Twitter at Tony Michaels POD at Tony
Michaels pod
that that bonehead of the week poll will
be there on Twitter also download every
single episode Apple Spotify Google why
you're there leave us a great review
because all the trolls I'm sure are
leaving reviews there while you're
subscribing don't forget to give us a
five star and say something great say
yeah Tony doesn't sneeze and Mike or he
tries not to sneeze in the microphone a
little
slow on the uptake for the mute button
but they did it and if you're on
Facebook right now you'll follow us at
the Tony Michaels we post some memes
over there I'll put some memes with some
curse words in it if you like that over
there on Facebook and also remember we
run on your support
we run on your support and it's not just
it's not just buying merch or if you
want to leave a tip it's also spreading
the message spread the message out there
get that message out to go show those to
go share those two movies that I that I
showed you now the the game is up
movie.com and then uh my uh the
brainwashing of my dad.com the
brainwashing of my dad.com again those
aren't sponsors those are just great
movies that you can share with people
not just your Maga relatives but people
who have model relatives go share those
movies with them because that's engaging
that's that's supporting us that's
supporting the cause because I don't
just mean our show I mean democracy in
general but if you like to support our
show
you can show your support by staying
warm at
store.thetonymichaels.com at
store.beattonymichaels.com you can get a
zip up Hoodie a pull over hoodie a
sweater you can even get a t-shirt
if you're in a part of the country where
it's not going to get too chilly but if
you want to stay warm grab you uh the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty this is our most
popular design right now these things
are flying off the shelves everyone
thank you for joining me today we will
see you same time same place tomorrow
tomorrow as always Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific right
here on YouTube Twitter twitch and
simulcasting on Facebook
you know the drill Surfs Up
[ __ ] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] em
foreign
[Music]